well there was a whole worm unit on the
movie literally called the worm unit
that they shot you know uh there's a
two-minute sequence in the movie or
something like that that took them four
months to shoot or something insane and
uh it was absolutely insane and uh
obviously the worm wasn't there on the
day so there is a certain process of
visualization but I thought was
fascinating they built very you know
specifically a tiny part of the worm
would sounds
weird would look like slab wor little
slab of worm can as one says that's even
weirder you just kind of yeah hook into
it yeah you know I don't know how what
did it feel like it felt uh it was
exhilarating and um and uh yeah there's
all these innuendos no but but um was
something that I feel like I don't want
to speak for Den I don't think they had
fully figured out at the end of the
first one there's a visual at a distance
at the end of the movie of someone
writing the sand warm so I think they
were sort of figuring out but there was
definitely a technique to it you know I
remember you know going to Z and you
know wishing that my arm arm technique
was different wait why because um just
you know visuals there's there's a real
frame of reference for writing a sand so
you're trying to do it cool you know and
make it look strong and so you're trying
to like okay do I hold like this do I
stand like this do I have my leg here do
I you know you're trying to have the
strongest worm writing pose at the end
of the day you know cuz it is it's film
making you know so you you're trying to
figure it out figure it out not just any
weird gonss well they CGI at all of
it